What's the deal with Islam and dogs? If
you've been paying any attention, surely
you've come to suspect that Muslims
simply don't like what is otherwise
known as man's best friend? I've already
written about this phenomena over the
years. Article links in the description.
But just in case you don't know about
what I'm talking about, here are a few
news clippings. In May 2025, just a few
days ago, the Muslim owner of a dog
rescue shelter in the UK called Savapaw
was arrested after the remains of 37
dead dogs were found at his premises.
Apparently, his scam was to take in the
pets of owners who could no longer keep
them on the promise that he would rehome
them for a fee. In January 2025, dogs
were reported as being slaughtered all
throughout the streets of Morocco with
an estimated 3 million set to be
exterminated as part of that Muslim
nation's preparations to host the 2030
World Cup in August of 2024. And in the
words of Turkish journalist Uzul, the
dog massacre law that the government of
Turkey passed on July 30 is causing a
rampage of cruelty by evil people in
Turkey. Municipalities are now hunting
down and massacring stray dogs,
sometimes including pets loved and cared
for, found in the neighborhoods of their
owners. Horrifying news is coming not
only from municipalities, but also from
private citizens. Those who hate dogs
are poisoning, shooting, and even
beheading dogs. Some are buried alive.
In November 2022, and in the words of
another local journalist, the mayor of
Hebrron, a Palestinian city, offered 20
shekels to anyone who kills a dog in his
city. Palestinians took to the streets
torturing and killing dozens of dogs.
The report is accompanied by a picture
of what appears to be Palestinians
beating a dog with sticks. In July 2022,
Iranian authorities raided dog shelters
and slaughtered 1,700 dogs that were
taken in as strays. According to the
report, heart-wrenching footage showed a
volunteer crying as she held the dogs.
One can go on and on with similar
stories and they're in my articles, but
I think you get the point. In short, you
may have heard that in Springfield,
they're eating the dogs, but in the
Muslim world, they're exterminating them
like vermin. Muslim hostility for dogs
has even reached and is causing problems
in the West. Reports of Muslim cab and
Uber drivers in the USA, Europe, Canada,
and Australia refusing to pick up blind
passengers because they're accompanied
by their seeing eye dogs are immensely
common, especially in that bastion of
diversity and multiculturalism, the
United Kingdom. In the UK, signs
forbidding the presence of dogs are not
uncommon in Muslim heavy regions. Okay,
so Muslim hate for dogs is a well
doumented phenomenon. It's a very real
thing. But where does it come from? As
with all questions concerning what is
and is not Islamic, we must turn to the
religion's founder, Muhammad. It's no
secret that according to many authentic
or sah hadiths, including the two most
authentic of all, Sah Bkari and Sah
Muslim, he demonized literally and
called for the killing of dogs. In the
words of Sah Muslim number 1572, quote,
"Allah's messenger ordered us to kill
dogs, and we carried out this order so
thoroughly that we even killed the dog
accompanying a woman from the desert. He
means the guard dog of an elderly
widow." After this dog genocide went on
for some time, and mind you, this is
before gunpowder, meaning the prophet's
followers zealously killed all these
dogs with knives, stones, through
strangulation, drowning, etc.
After a while, Muhammad revised his
command and limited the killings to just
black dogs. What the Sah Muslim hadith
continues, quote, "Then Allah's
messenger forbade their killing, and he
said, you should kill the jet black dog
with two spots above the eyes, for it is
a devil. So far, so good. At least now
we know where all the modern-day Muslim
hostility for dogs comes from, the
Muslim prophet." Now, what's
interesting, however, is if we put on
our detective hats and piece together
all the reasons as to why Muhammad hated
dogs. I direct your attention to exhibit
A, another Sah hadith. According to it,
Gabriel the angel made an appointment
with Muhammad. The angel said he'd visit
Muhammad very late at a specific night.
Muhammad waited and waited, but Gabriel
never showed up, leaving the messenger
of Allah most frustrated. The canonical
hadith narrated by one of Muhammad's
wives Aisha is also found in Sahhat
Muslim depending on the version either
number 21104 or 5244 and it goes as
follows. Keep in mind Aisha is narrating
quote Gabriel made an appointment to
meet the messenger of Allah but the hour
came and he did not arrive. The prophet
had a staff in his hand and he threw it
down out of frustration and said Allah
and his messengers do not break their
promises. Then looking around, he saw a
small puppy beneath his bed. Ya, cried
he, "When did this dog enter?" "By
Allah," squeaked the scared little girl.
"I don't know." So he ordered the dog
out. Then Gabriel came. And the
messenger of Allah said, "You promised
me and I sat waiting for you, but you
did not come." Gabriel replied, "It was
the dog in your house that prevented me.
We do not enter a house that contains a
dog."
Okay, so according to this authentic
hadith which Muslims accept, Gabriel
made an appointment to meet with
Muhammad at night. But for whatever
reason, the presence of a puppy
prevented this almighty angel from
entering Muhammad's abode. That for
starters is rather strange behavior for
an angel. In the Bible, for instance,
angels don't seem to be so scared of
animals. For example, when Satan tempted
Jesus in the desert for 40 days, Jesus,
we learn, was quote, with the wild
animals and angels attended him. Mark
1:13. Nor did the presence of flocks of
sheep and other unclean farm animals
prevent angels, literally the heavenly
hosts, from appearing and proclaiming
Christ's birth in their midst. Luke
2:8:20. There are many other examples
including from the Old Testament such as
Balam's donkey which interacts with and
recognizes the presence of an angel
before the human does. That's numbers
22:21-35. So what is it that scared
Gabriel from a puppy under Muhammad's
bed? Could it be that the angel was
afraid the dog would start barking if he
approached the house as dogs are want to
do and therefore cause a scene waking
neighbors up at such an ungodly hour?
Maybe if Gabriel wasn't Gabriel. And
here is where the plot thickens. Enter
Dea Al Kalbi, exhibit number two, a
close companion of Muhammad and his
junior by 22 years. Not only do early
Islamic sources and hadith obsess over
this man's unparalleled beauty, Dea was
the most gorgeous man I ever saw. Even
little Aisha once proclaimed, but
apparently the angel Gabriel was in the
habit of taking on the form of Dea
during his nighttime rendevouses with
Muhammad. Sound familiar? This comes out
clearly in several authentic hadiths.
Thus, according to another Sah Muslim
hadith number 601, one night while
Muhammad was at the home of another of
his
wives, someone came a visiting late at
night. Taking a peek, she said, quote,
"By Allah, this is none other than
Kelby." Verbatim, I'm quoting the hadith
for you. When Muhammad returned, she
inquired, "Oh messenger of Allah, who
was that?" To which Muhammad replied,
"That was Gabriel, come bringing
teachings of your religion."
Okay, so let's put it all together and
read as it were between the lines. And
please keep in mind that as with Alzot,
the tall naked black men who rode
Muhammad during that other infamous
night in the desert, these are not my
deductions or conclusions. Rather, I am
once again sharing with you what is
being said by ex-Muslims throughout the
Arab world, their contentions against
Islam. The claim has long been made that
as with al- zot, Muhammad had a
homosexual relationship with albi, this
most beautiful of men. But because
homosexuality was of course frowned upon
by the Arabs of Muhammad's time,
especially by anyone claiming to be a
prophet of God, he and Dea had to meet
secretly, often in the night. So they
came up with a plan. If anyone saw them
together, Dea would pretend to be
Gabriel on the notion that the
apparently vain angel was desirous of
taking on the handsome man's guys
whenever manifesting in the flesh to
meet with Muhammad. Of course, this begs
the question, why didn't Gabriel take on
an independent and even more handsome
form of a man? Why did he always choose
the already pre-existing appearance of
Dea? Kind of makes you wonder, though,
what a rather convenient excuse whenever
Muhammad's wives saw Dea with the
prophet late at night in their homes.
At any rate, now let's return to and
apply all this information to Aisha's
important hadith about that little puppy
dog. You will recall that she said
Gabriel had made an appointment to meet
Muhammad that night. However, no matter
how long Muhammad waited, no angel
appeared. Looking around, a visibly
frustrated Muhammad is spied a little
dog in his house, which he promptly
ordered Aisha to kick out. Having done
so, Gabriel finally appeared, confirming
that he refused to approach because a
dog was in the house. The meaning, as
many ex and highly disaffected Muslims
insist, should be plain enough.
According to them, this late night
visitation by Gabriel was by none other
than De Albby. However, seeing that a
dog had entered Muhammad's house, he
refused to approach lest the dog start
barking, thereby creating a scene in the
middle of the night, causing all the
neighbors to wake up and come out, see
what's going on. Once Muhammad became
aware of all this, he already suspected
the puppy was the reason for his angel's
delay since he had it kicked out. And
because the prophet of Allah didn't want
to encounter this problem ever again and
maybe even in a rage to avenge himself
on those pesky barking animals, he
ordered the ritual slaying of all dogs
in
Medina. How sad to think that this is
the reason that till this very day,
nearly 14 centuries later, Muslims still
hate and kill dogs. Without giving it
any further thought, all that Muslims
are taught is that angels won't enter
homes with dogs and that some dogs, such
as black ones, are demonpossessed. So
they despise and as seen kill them. If
you don't believe me, consider the words
of a fetwa on the highly respected
Muslim website Islam Q&A. It concludes
by saying, quote, "We must ensure that
Muslims continue to be averse to dogs
even in the midst of what the
non-Muslims are used to doing and what
some Muslims have adopted of their
habits. And Allah knows best." In other
words, Muslims living in the west might
assimilate and ease their stance towards
dogs and heaven forbid even start liking
them. No, he's saying this fatwa. We
must make sure they remain averse to
dogs. Perhaps the saddest point of all
is that because topics like this are
politically incorrect and cannot be
acknowledged in the west. The west
remains complicit in the abuse of dogs.
According to a report titled, quote, "US
spends millions to train bomb sniffing
dogs gifted to Arab countries that abuse
them. Many of the nations that the US
gifts these highly trained dogs, which
include Bahrain, Lebanon, Egypt,
Indonesia, Morocco, and Syria, have well
doumented records of abusing and killing
dogs like
Vernon. Before closing, I would be
remiss if I did not point out that there
is yet another interpretation behind
Muhammad's animus for dogs, an even
older and more diabolical one. According
to this rendition, Gabriel was indeed an
angel, but a fallen angel, a demon, if
not Satan himself. Hence why he feared
and hated dogs who according to many
world traditions including if not
especially Christian traditions are
known to see and bark at evil spirits
lurking in the night. Therefore he Satan
possessed his minion Muhammad into
killing and teaching Muslims to kill
man's best friend. The fact that Dea al
Kalb's last name which signifies his
tribe literally means the dog in a
twisted way almost validates this
interpretation. Anyway, now you know
where Muslim animosity for dogs comes
from.